and finally real quick here
i do want to
mention one other story that happened
this week because i found this just
absolutely fascinating and that is of
course the fact that mo brooks
the now lame duck republican member of
congress because he lost his uh runoff
election this week to katie britt
came out shortly after losing that
election and said you know what
i think i'm ready
to sit down with the january 6 committee
now
now he had previously been subpoenaed
however he had not been served his
subpoena because he was back home and
campaigning trying to win the race that
he ultimately lost
but the timing of that sure is
interesting isn't it
now that the dust has settled now that
he knows his political career is at
least at a temporary end
now he says i'll go ahead and talk to
you
now of course he does have some
stipulations here's what he says he says
my basic requirement is it be in public
so the public can see it so they don't
get bits and pieces dribbled out fine
i'm good with that
he also wants to see the material they
have on him and the questions that
they're going to be asking ahead of time
okay i'll give you that as well
but i do not think it is a coincidence
that he has finally agreed to talk to
this committee that of course is clearly
going after donald trump
after he lost his election
possibly because donald trump pulled his
endorsement from him
i think mo brooks is out for revenge
and i think mo brooks understands that
the best way to get that revenge on
donald trump
is to go sit down with that committee
and tell them everything they know
mo brooks of course as everybody
remembers is the guy that wore the
bulletproof vest to go speak at the stop
the steel rally
it has also been reported
he says it's not true but it has been
reported
that members of his staff were actually
working with the stop the steel
organizers to help put the whole thing
together
so mo brooks has some things to tell
no doubt about that mo brooks has some
stories to tell
and i hope that he gets the chance to
tell them now ordinarily i would not
be in favor of the committee giving in
to his demands right you've subpoenaed
him you don't have to give in to
anything
but
if it means getting dirt on trump that
we otherwise might not get because
brooks wants to challenge it in court or
whatever he may choose to do
i say give in
put him on tv put it back in prime time
and let everybody hear what little mo
brooks has to say
about donald trump the man who screwed
him over
in his quest to be a united states
senator
we have to take a quick break but you
can get more from me on my youtube
channels check me out at youtube.com
slash the ring of fire and youtube.com
fair and balanced i'm fair and cousins
in for david pakman and we'll be back
with more